actually yes i do i think that in the  end I think that religious literacy  today given the way the world is is as  important as lots of other things we  take for granted in our schooling so I  would like to get to the point where our  educational programs are considered just  a program that says cultural religious  education means also learning about  other phase is just accepted I mean you  can't force people to do it but I think  you can offer them the prospect and as I  say when it happens people actually do  enjoy doing it so but i think this  doesn't this can be sanctioned by  government and helped by government it  doesn't need to be run by government and  may well be better that it's not